nobody knows for certain what awaits us
in Andromeda though our long-range scans
have provided a map there are no
guarantees on a voyage that will take us
to 0.5 million light-years away from her
that's where the Pathfinder team comes
in my name is Cora Harper
second-in-command on the human
Pathfinder team it's our job to find and
secure potential golden worlds identify
settlement sites and start the process
of building our new home we act under
our own authority and represent the tip
of the spear in Andromeda every arc has
its own team and every team has its own
Pathfinder senior mission officers
experts in survival diplomacy and if it
fails combat our Pathfinder on our
criterion is Alec Ryder
whose pioneering service history speaks
for itself a skilled soldier within
seven ranking and talented scientist
Ryder was a member of the original Task
Force who traveled through the Karen
mass relay and took humanity's first
steps across the galaxy
now he's preparing us to tackle the next
great frontier Andromeda liam
specializes in crisis response every
team needs its idealist and liam is ours
Sarah and Scott Reiter
are pathfinders son and daughter and
former Alliance recruits fresh off tours
with the Arcturus station outpost and
Prothean artifacts team respectively
and myself lieutenant Cora Harper to be
brief I'm a biotic the team's operations
specialist in charge of ground missions
and I spent the last four years serving
alongside asari commandos and finally
our last team member Sam short for
simulated adaptive matrix Sam is an
artificial intelligence and designed by
our pathfinder himself from his node in
the arc Sam receives a direct feed of
the Pathfinders sensory input via a
neural implant it sees and feels as
Ryder does providing him advanced
situational awareness problem-solving
and even tactical enhancements
finder team receive implant allowing
them to communicate directly with Sam
the individuals who make up this team
could have represents a chance for the
bravest
and the brightest account
it takes to join us we'll make sure
there's a bunk on the tempest
you
[Music]